(STAMMERS)
Um, sorry. Uh...
(YELPS)
(CHUCKLES) Sorry about this.
♪ (UPBEAT STRING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER:
He's not a natural showman.
He does get nervous.
RICHARD BRANSON: My mum tried
to get us over our shyness,
to challenge ourselves.
EVE BRANSON: We allowed them
to do a lot of dangerous things.
That's led onto
a few more daring things.
VANESSA BRANSON:
He thrives on jeopardy.
It's a continuation
of his childhood.
RICHARD:
Having suffered from dyslexia,
having left school at 15,
I had a lot to prove.
SPEAKER: He is a bundle
of contradictions.
SPEAKER 2: People were seduced
into thinking that
this was a bumbling, good guy,
when, in fact,
Richard always had a very
firm eye on the bottom line.
RICHARD: We had to use
every trick in the book.
SPEAKER 3:
I don't believe that Virgin
could be what it is today
if he hadn't have done
the boat crossings
and the balloon crossings.
We're going to space.
RICHARD: Risk taking is a drug.
A drug that started as a child
and has continued into my life
ever since.
SPEAKER 2: Richard was capable
of spending every single penny
on some project
that was gonna lose it all.
VANESSA: We've never
taken it for granted,
that this can all
just disappear.
Poof.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
RICHARD: The spaceship's had
a catastrophic failure.
It's just ghastly all around.
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
If you've learnt the art
of trying the impossible,
you can turn that to
trying to do the impossible
with anything.
SPEAKER 4:
That is the gift he has.
RICHARD: There is a danger that,
by having that attitude,
that it could go horribly wrong.
I just feel that you should
throw yourself into life.
Life is short, anyway.
And I think it should be lived
to its full.